hallo und herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live viele haben es mitbekommen es
hat die ganze nacht wieder geregnet
wassermassen im westen deutschlands
flüsse sind über die ufer getretene
bäche sind zu reißenden strömen geworden
und auch in wuppertal ging es mit viel
wasser her vor ort ist unser kollege
thomas münten und der hat die ganze
nacht über schon berichtet für die
verschiedenen formate wir dürfen ihnen
jetzt noch mal fragen wie es aussieht
thomas vielen dank erstmal so hat die
lehren so guten morgen guten morgen
es ist im moment so dass man sagen muss
die lage hat sich auf den ersten blick
ein ganz klein wenig entspannt gestern
abend war sehr sehr kritisch geworden
weil die wuppertalsperre in radevormwald
die ganz am ende dieses kleinen flusses
liegt drohte überzulaufen dann hat man
sie ein wenig geöffnet übergelaufen ist
sie dann aber trotzdem genauso wie die
bevertalsperre direkt daneben und das
ergebnis dieses überlaufe sieht man hier
wenn man einmal in den jetzt reißenden
fluss schaut hier an der alexander
brücke das gebäude hier ist sozusagen
eine schwebebahn haltestelle die
schwebebahn fährt aber nicht und dieser
fluss hier ist normalerweise ja sagen
wir mal zweieinhalb drei meter breit und
vielleicht 70 cm bis einen meter tief im
moment haben wir hier zwölf bis 15 meter
breite bei drei meter vierzig wasserhöhe
und genau das ist das problem denn die
stadt wuppertal liegt rund um diesen
fluss herum und zwar tiefer als der
fluss große teile der altstadt liegen
hinter dieser mauer und dann geht es
ungefähr so einen halben meter runter
das heißt wenn da wasser eindringt wenn
das wasser über diese barriere kommt
dann läuft die wuppertaler altstadt
komplett voll sagen heute morgen dann
auch schon gesehen einen apotheken- und
arzt gebäude das direkt an der wupper
gebaut war
da ist durch die belüftungsanlage wasser
eingedrungen und hat die apotheke die im
erdgeschoss sie hat den keller und die
apotheke ungefähr 50 cm hoch geflutet
soll heißen wasserhöhe im gebäude
ungefähr drei meter entspannung deswegen
weil es heute nacht aufgehört hat zu
regnen heute morgen hatte sogar so ein
bisschen mal die sonne geschienen
aber wenn man jetzt schaut dann bezieht
es sich schon wieder es wird schon
wieder warm es wird schon wieder feucht
das heißt neuer regen könnte sich
ankündigen
und das würde bedeuten dass dann die
situation hier wieder deutlich schlimmer
wird das gleiche gilt leider auch für
die gebiete weiler euskirchen düsseldorf
erkrath düsseldorf gerresheim
überall dort wo es eigentlich kleine
flüsse gibt die düssel an der fluss der
düsseldorf den namen gibt der aber
normalerweise touristisch sehr schön
sich mitten durch die gründe es alle
zieht er ist so über die ufer getreten
dass in erkrath unmengen von schotter
transportiert worden
dasselbe in hagen-hohenlimburg
hohenlimburg wurde komplett mit schotter
zugestellt altena es von der außenwelt
im moment abgeschlossen kann man mit dem
auto nicht erreichen
ganz besonders schlimm schuld bei aachen
vier häuser sind eingestürzt 30 personen
werden vermisst zwei feuerwehrleute sind
gestern abend gestorben in ahrweiler
auch tote die situation ist immer noch
angespannt und das schlimme ist es wird
vorerst auch so bleiben denn was jetzt
hier ankommt landet irgendwann in rhein
und ruhr
das führt dann dazu dass diese flüsse
wieder steigen das heißt die leute in
köln in düsseldorf in rothenkirchen
können sich jetzt schon wieder darauf
vorbereiten dass das nächste hochwasser
kommen wird was dann auch wieder sie
betrifft die einzige hoffnung diesem
moment gibt es eben dass es jetzt so
auszusehen scheint als wenn das liebste
wirklich durch wäre
meteorologisch gesehen haben wir eben
auf dem radar geschaut kommt da jetzt
nichts großes mehr nach erst einmal
heute abend vielleicht noch aber ob sich
jetzt hier in dieser feucht-warmen luft
wieder neue gewitterzellen bilden das
weiß natürlich keiner kann mehr angeht
sieht ebenfalls nicht wirklich gut aus
und wir gehen damit zurück nach mainz
vielen dank thomas münten für diese
auskünfte und für diese berichte das
sieht gar nicht gut aus hinter ihnen
aber erstmal vielen dank so weit wir
sprechen jetzt im studio mit dem diplom
meteorologen erst intelli und der
soll uns einmal erklären wie das alles
zustande kommt wo kommt dieser regen her
diese wassermassen
ja es ist ja dieses tief dieses
dauertief quasi was über uns hinweg
zieht aber das passiert so langsam dass
es eben sehr viel zeit hat lange feucht
warme luft aus dem mittelmeer zu uns her
zu führen und feucht warme luft ist
quasi der treibstoff für gewitter für
dieses starkregen ereignis und das
passiert halt durchgehend permanent weil
es sich eben nicht weg bewegt es dreht
sich im gegen den uhrzeigersinn und
dabei werden halt große regenmengen in
einer region abgeladen man muss sich
vorstellen wenn da quasi ein gebirge ist
zum beispiel die eifel dann strömt der
regen immer dagegen und da regnet es
dann besonders kräftig und es hat in den
letzten 24 stunden 50 bis 100 liter auf
den quadratmeter gegeben aber
flächendeckend also nicht irgendwie
lokal wie bei einem gewitter sondern
über große flächen teilweise über eine
fläche von drittel von nordrhein
westfalen ist so viel wasser runter
gekommen also das ist schon enorm
wo kommt denn so ein phänomen her also
das ist ja tatsächlich noch nicht
dagewesen katastrophalen manchen gebeten
wie wie kommt es zu so viel und so einer
was die massierung oder das wird den
schwerpunkt ist ja erklärt aber wie
kommt es überhaupt so was das sind ja
jahrhundert ereignisse zum teil ja also
grundsätzlich muss man sagen wir leben
in der klimakrise und die wetter-
extreme nehmen zu hier gibt es einen
zusammenhang oder ziemlich eindeutig
weltweit passiert das und das hängt in
erster linie mit dem jetstream zusammen
der ist auf abwegen und dieses tief hat
sich abgekoppelt und dreht sich quasi
über uns hat mit dem eigenen mit der
eigentlichen strömungen nicht mehr so
viel zu tun und ist auch noch von hochs
umgeben das bedeutet dass tief ist
gefangen und deswegen bewegte sich auch
fast gar nicht so oder sehr sehr langsam
das ändert sich ja dann morgen da kommt
eine nördliche strömung auf dann wird
das tief allmählich abgedrängt
aber diese veränderung in den strömungen
in den in den höheren luftschichten
in im jet stream quasi dass es auf die
klimakrise zurückzuführen denn die
strömung verändern sich und das
beobachten wir seit einigen jahren
jetzt ist das dieselbe seite der
medaille muss man sagen zum beispiel bei
hitzewellen
da hätte man so ein tief über frankreich
über spanien und ein hoch über uns und
da wird über lange zeit wenn es da fest
sitzen würde wie wir es jetzt zum
beispiel 2018 über lange zeit hatten
wird über lange zeit die warme luft zu
uns geführt und das hoch würde es weiter
erwärmen durch das absinken
dieses absinken dieses erwärmt das
hatten wir ja auch das ist ein normaler
vorgang aber das passiert dann
und dieses ganze massive das hatten wir
mit dem hit um zum beispiel über
nordamerika und kanada wo diese
exorbitanten temperaturen gemessen
wurden also hier ist ganz klar der der
fußabdruck der klimakrise drin
wir sprechen gleich nochmal was das
wetter weiter auch bringt denn wir haben
es ja von thomas münten gehört es wird
wieder warm so ein bisschen sonne also
das ist alles sehr wechselvoll darüber
sprechen wir gleich noch mal
jetzt aber sehen wir erst mal bilder aus
solingen hat es eben auch zu
überschwemmungen geführt das wetter und
das wollen wir uns in einem beitrag
anschauen
da wird in vielen teilen nordrhein
westfalens gegen die wassermassen gegen
die überflutungen gekämpft anwohner
innen helfer hilfskräfte sind da schwer
dabei und zwei feuerwehrleute sind ums
leben gekommen
bad münstereifel iversheim alles reißt
die strömung mit keiner weiß was in den
fässern und containern ist oder war
alles schwimmt der notruf ist überlastet
in den straßen steht hüfthoch das wasser
es gibt stromausfälle
der damm der steinbachtalsperre in
euskirchen droht zu brechen
gleiche dramatische bilder aus altena
durch die straßen schießt das wasser wer
von der einen seite auf die andere will
ist auf motorisierte hilfe angewiesen
oder muss sich alternativen ausdenken
alarm in der nacht in wuppertal in den
straßen sind waren fahrzeuge unterwegs
fordern die menschen auf zu hause zu
bleiben
viele straßen sind nicht mehr passierbar
der bahnverkehr ist eingeschränkt nach
dem überlaufen der talsperre befürchtet
die stadt wuppertal jetzt weitere
überschwemmungen starkregen gab es
vielerorts vor allem im westen
deutschlands haben jetzt mehrfach gehört
dramatische zustände auch im rheinland
pfälzischen annweiler dort kamen
mindestens vier menschen ums leben
der ort schuld ist besonders betroffen
entschuldigung ach so zu dem ortsschild
wo sechs häuser eingestürzt sind so
werden etwa noch 70 menschen vermisst
zwei dutzend weitere gebäude sind laut
polizei einsturzgefährdet also da ist
noch gar keine entwarnung in sicht
vorher schon hatte der kreis vulkaneifel
den katastrophenfall ausgerufen und auch
hilfe von der bundeswehr angefordert
einige orte sind wegen des hochwassers
nicht mehr erreichbar noch mal die frage
an unseren betten experten hier ist
intel ii das wetter verändert sich
bleibt gleich wir haben gehört es bleibt
erst mal sowas ist aber für diese orte
ungefähr zu prognostizieren also es gibt
heute noch regen und auch gewitter sind
noch unterwegs
die kommen wieder aus der selben
richtung quasi aus nordost ziehen sie
rein und gewitter sind dann auch dabei
man muss jetzt nochmal mit regenmengen
von etwa 40 bis 60 liter obendrauf als
maximalmenge dazurechnet kann
mancherorts auch ein bisschen weniger
geben aber es kommt eben noch einmal
regen dazu und auch morgen regnet es
aber morgen im laufe des tages wird sich
das allmählich entspannen
heute muss man also quasi noch mal durch
diese durch diese unwetterlage durch
vielen dank ist in terni soweit wir
haben jetzt die möglichkeit mit einem
kreis beigeordneten des kreises bitburg
prüm zu sprechen das ist der herr rudolf
rinnen der uns zugeschaltet ist und da
wollte ich fragen erst mal vielen dank
dass sie es möglich machen dass wir
sprechen können sie einmal kurz
schildern wie es bei ihnen aussieht
ja wir haben eine absolute großlage
flächenmäßig starke regenfälle über 252
ufer trat mit der seit gestern abend
haben uns priorität ist darauf gesetzt
dass wir einfach so wir wollen
menschenleben retten vorhabe und gut
weil wir haben verschiedenste
eingeschlossene personen gehabt wir
haben sogar drei retter gehabt die sich
in einer rettung einer sechsköpfigen
familie selber indem es
eben haben nicht mehr als ufer kamen und
sich am fahrzeugdach festgehalten haben
von schweren lkw und werden nach fünf
stunden haben wir diese drei retter
retten können sie können sich vorstellen
dass das natürlich an den hilfskräften
auch nicht einfach so vorbei geht wenn
die kollegen die vorher noch gerettet
haben selber gerettet werden müssen
wir haben mit aktuellen haus ein stück
start wo wir zwei personen retten
konnten sind mental fünf personen mit
dem schweren kran wo wir gar nicht mehr
hinkommen weil die wassermassen so groß
sind dass mit dem fahrzeug hin kommen
wir haben auch leider keine hubschrauber
bekommen weder von den amerikanischen
streitkräften noch von der polizei war
das möglich dass ein hubschrauber
überhaupt bei uns landet ja und jetzt
sind wir an den fünf personen daran die
mittels 1 100 meter krans zu retten weil
das haus auch grob jahr konkret
gefährdet ist und wir wissen nicht ob
das haus noch lange durch stellen also
wie satz priorität moment einfach auf
retten von menschen und sich selber die
retter nicht selber in gefahr bringen
und alles andere kommt hinterher
wie viele kräfte sind denn im moment im
einsatz bei ihnen die viele menschen
sind da unterwegs um zu helfen und die
wörter und nacht über 1000 kräfte im
einsatz aus dem eifelkreis haben dann in
der nacht alarmiert was überhaupt unsere
bremer aus gelnhausen aus der pfalz aus
dem haus laut dunking von zwillingen die
airbase spangdahlem material und
personal geschickt also wir haben
wirklich in allen facetten versucht
rettungskräfte zu bekommen sie können
sich vorstellen unsere unser personal
war bereits 14 50 stunden im einsatz
die brauchen auch mal drei vier stunden
schlaf und deshalb bin ich sehr dankbar
dass die kollegen aus dem stall von
rheinland pfalz und auch als nachbarn
denn dann einfach schnell vor ort waren
heute nach zwischen gesetzt haben mit
material mit stromaggregaten mit
technischem material gekommen sind und
einfach hier mithelfen als wir haben
rund 1500 kräfte moment im einsatz
speziell zum einsatz gehabt es ist eine
schadenslage die dir so setzt 2018 bei
dem hohen hochwasser nicht hatten
wir haben den ganzen landkreis
großflächig unter wasser und haben das
technische
beziehungsprobleme kein telefon kein
funknetz nichts mehr
75 straßen zurzeit gesperrt das ist das
was im moment wissen unsere straßen also
da ist alles dabei
und wie sagt wir sind im moment dabei
wirkt die menschen zu schauen und
versuchen da ja mal ein überblick zu
bekommen
dass wir auch wissen wo müssen wir da
ansetzen bei nicht aller rettungskräfte
überhaupt irgendwo hinfahren konnten
weil die straßen überflutet brücken
wir haben drei brücken verloren bis
jetzt ist droht weitere brücken
einzustürzen weggeschwemmt zu werden
das ist eine situation also die habe ich
so auch noch nie erlebt und erwartet sie
haben jetzt gesagt sie haben schon hilfe
bekommen allerdings können hubschrauber
nicht landen
aber wie kann man ihnen noch mal besser
bei stehen was könnten sie sich dann
noch vorstellen
ja ich sag mal so also wir haben alles
alarmiert was überhaupt noch sichtbar
war wo wir sagen das brauchen wir die
leute einfach braunau von manpower das
ist im moment das was die nachbarkreis
bzw auch brauchen weil wir haben halt in
vulkaneifelkreis aber da haben sie eben
genannt aber auch hier sah bus also die
ganze region der westeifel ist hier
stark betroffen und wir können natürlich
nicht aus den nachbarkreisen personal ab
ziemlich die hätten uns wahrscheinlich
sonst gern geholfen aber sind selber
land unter
von daher sage ich schon mal wir sind
froh dass sie aus dem südlichen bereich
von rheinland pfalz die kräfte direkt
hier hingekommen sind heute nacht
losgefahren und jetzt ja mitten im
einsatz stecken vor allem eine
technische einsatzleitung der funk
leitung aber auch natürlich vor auch die
kolleginnen und kollegen die kameraden
sind da wirklich überaus engagiert und
ich bin absolut dankbar dass wir diese
hilfe schnell unbürokratisch von der
ganzen blaulicht familien bekommen thw
feuerwehr egal
rotes kreuz als jeder hat hier
mitgeholfen sonst wäre die situation
eine noch gravierender die sich jetzt
schon da stellen wir haben und nicht im
gesamten überblick
vielen dank herr innen für das gespräch
und dass sie die zeit gefunden haben in
so einer lage uns kurz auf den stand zu
bringen wir wünschen ihnen vom ganzen
team von der ganzen redaktion viel kraft
wie viel energie in diesem fall und
alles gute
zwischen zu schlafen aber ich glaube es
gibt mit wenig schlaf jetzt die nächsten
fünf tage auch passen sie auf sich auf
vielen dank nochmal wir sprechen noch
mal sprechen noch mal mit essent ali wir
haben es vorher gehört wechselvoll viel
regen wie geht es jetzt weiter für
diesen ganzen bereich kann man da schon
ein bisschen was absehen
ja es wird also noch weiterregnen heute
aber dass erst einmal mit schauern und
auch gewittern
es kann auch zeitweise regnen das
bedeutet dann über längere zeit
insgesamt müssen wir wieder mit größeren
regenmengen rechnen 50 bis 60 liter
heute im tagesverlauf noch im westen vor
allem westlich des rheins also auch
wieder richtung eifel und weiter südlich
also ist es noch nicht durchgestanden es
kommt noch einmal reden oben drauf und
dann verlagert sich dieses tief
allmählich weiter südwärts aber auch im
süden deutschlands wird es regnen und
dann morgen im laufe des freitags wird
es langsam abgedrängt der regen lässt
dann allmählich nach also es ist noch
ist es noch nicht ganz vorbei du sagst
jetzt es geht in den süden deutschlands
wird es da ähnlich schlimm werden sage
ich mal länder ähnliche maßen kommen
worauf muss man sich da dann einstellen
ähnliche massen nicht mehr ist und dann
tatsächlich schauer und gewitter als
kann punktuell dann doch mal
unterschritten aber das tief hat sich
nun schon ziemlich ausgetobt muss man
sagen und auch die zufuhr der
feucht-warmen luft aus dem mittelmeer
von südosten teilweise die fast
ungehindert zu uns gekommen ist die wird
allmählich nun aber unterbrochen und
damit verliert das tief auch seine kraft
und dann dreht die strömung halt morgen
auch im tagesverlauf allmählich auf nord
und dann wird es allmählich in den süden
abgedrängt aber schauer und gewitter
sind immer noch dabei am wochenende vor
allem im süden deutschlands also es
bleibt erst einmal auch nicht unbedingt
trocken
vielen dank ist sind alle solchen
einschätzungen für diese erklärungen die
immer wichtiger werden
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
armin laschet hat jetzt angekündigt
gegen 12 uhr eine pressekonferenz zu
machen und sich da noch mal zu äußern
wir informieren sie natürlich und euch
weiter über alle kanäle die uns zur
verfügung stehen
über die app die zdf- heute- app über
facebook youtube und alle kanäle auch
den analogen also um 12 uhr punkt gibt
es noch mal wieder die heute nachrichten
im fernsehen
vielen dank für euer interesse für ihr
interesse
für alle die die im katastrophengebiet
gerade sich befinden alles gute und viel
kraft und es dann